SPEAKER BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
EASE AND NOT A STRAIGHT LINE.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LITTLE
WHILE, AND THAT'S OKAY.
>> LAWMAKERS GEARING UP FOR
POTENTIALLY A DRAMATIC AND LATE
DAY HERE ON CAPITOL HILL WHERE
THE 118th CONGRESS IS ABOUT TO
BE SWORN IN IN A FEW HOURS FROM
NOW.
AND BEATING FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP ENDORSED CANDIDATE
REPUBLICAN JOE KENT FLIPPING A
FORMERLY REPUBLICAN-HELD SEAT IN
A DISTRICT THAT VOTED FOR TRUMP
TWICE TO DEMOCRATS.
CONGRESSWOMAN-ELECT PEREZ IS
WITH US NOW THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
IT MUST BE REMARKABLE TO BE YOUR
FIRST DAY IN WASHINGTON.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SWORN IN.
I KNOW A LOT OF YOUR FAMILY IS
HERE AND YOU'RE WATCHING ALL OF
THIS DRAMA PLAY OUT ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT ALL?
>> I THINK DRAMA IS A GREAT WORD
FOR IT.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
I DON'T THINK THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN IS PAYING A WHOLE LOT
OF ATTENTION OR INSPIRED WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THIS CHAOS.
SO IT'S DEFINITELY INTERESTING,
BUT --
>> SEE IT MORE AS A DISTRACTION?
>> IT MATTERS HAVING A LEADER
THAT CAN GET STUFF DONE, THAT
CAN FIX THINGS, WORK ACROSS THE
AISLE, THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT MATTERS TO NORMAL
WORKING FAMILIES LIKE MINE.
KEVIN'S NOT THAT PERSON.
HE'S NEVER GOING TO BE THAT
PERSON WHO CAN WORK ACROSS THE
AISLE AND DELIVER.
I THINK IT'S -- EVEN IF FOLKS
AREN'T PAYING A LOT OF ATTENTION
TO IT, YOU KNOW IT DOES MATTER.
>> YEAH.
IT DOES MATTER.
THERE'S A UNITY CANDIDATE
POTENTIALLY EMERGING IF IT DOES
DEVOLVE INTO CHAOS TODAY AND
MAYBE SOMEONE THAT DEMOCRATS
WOULD ACTUALLY COME ACROSS THE
AISLE AND VOTE FOR.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU AND
OTHER FRESHMEN DISCUSSED BEHIND
THE SCENES?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF FOLKS ARE
DISCUSSING IT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS I
RESPECT AND THINK WOULD DO A
MUCH, MUCH BETTER JOB.
SO I THINK IT WILL BE AN ACT OF
GOD IF WE CAN DELIVER A UNITY
CANDIDATE, BUT IT WOULD BE GREAT
FOR AMERICAN.
>> WHICH REPUBLICANS WOULD THAT
BE?
>> HONESTLY NAMING NAMES AT THIS
POINT IS PROBABLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND I'M NOT IN
LEADERSHIP.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE A MEMBER
WHO'S A PARTY INSIDER AND
SPENDING A LOT OF ENERGY
THINKING ABOUT LEADERSHIP
QUESTIONS.
SO I'M -- I AM VERY INTERESTED
TO SEE WHAT TODAY -- TODAY WILL
NOT BE BORING T. WILL NOT BE
BORING, SAFE TO SAY.
YOU HAVE A FASCINATING WIN AS WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
DISTRICT YOU WON IN.
VOTED FOR TRUMP TWICE.
UP AGAINST THIS TRUMP-BACKED
OPPONENT AND YOU HAD AN APPEAL
DURING YOUR CAMPAIGN THAT LOOKED
DIFFERENT THAN OTHER DEMOCRATS
WORKED ON ACROSS COUNTRY.
THIS WORKING-CLASS APPEAL.
I WONDER HOW YOU ARE GOING TO
USE THAT TO SHAPE YOUR TIME HERE
IN WASHINGTON?
>> YEAH.
WORKING FOR A LIVING.
WORKING IN THE TRADES.
BEING A RURAL AMERICAN, WHAT MY
PRIORITIES ARE AND PROBABLY WHY
I DON'T CARE TOO MUCH ABOUT THE
LEADERSHIP QUESTIONS AND THIS
DRAMA.
IT'S HOW DO WE MAKE LIVES
MEASURABLY BETTER.
MY SMALL BUSINESS BROKEN INTO
FOUR TIMES NOW.
JUST GOT BROKEN INTO AGAIN A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
I HAD A CAR STOLEN A FEW WEEKS
AGO.
IT'S A REALLY DIFFICULT TIME FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE, AND IT'S JUST
SO MUCH OF THIS, IT FEELS LIKE
DRAMA.
>> DO YOU THINK MEMBERS OF YOUR
PARTY ARE PAYING ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO ISSUES LIKE?
LIKE CRIME, LIKE THE THINGS
YOU'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
YOURSELF?
>> I DON'T THINK -- I THINK
T
THAT -- WHAT I'VE SEEN IS THAT
TO GET ELECTED, TO BE IN
CONGRESS TAKES SO MUCH MONEY.
IT TAKES SO MUCH -- SUCH A
NETWORK.
I THINK IT'S REALLY, REALLY HARD
FOR NORMAL PEOPLE TO BE ELECTED
INTO CONGRESS, AND I FEEL REALLY
GRATEFUL TO HAVE HAD THIS UNIQUE
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE I WAS
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH MY
DISTRICT AND ABLE TO PUT MY
EXPERIENCES TO USE IN A WAY I
THINK WILL SERVE MY DISTRICT
WELL.
>> WHAT CAN LEADER, DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS ON CAPITOL HILL LEARN
FROM THAT EXPERIENCE AND FROM
YOU?
>> WELL -- I DON'T THINK IT'S
REALLY ABOUT ME.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT ME AS
AN INDIVIDUAL.
I THINK IT'S MORE ABOUT SORT OF
THE OVERRIDING PRINCIPLES OF
BUILDING A CONGRESS THAT LOOKS
MORE LIKE AMERICA.
I THINK THAT THE CANDIDATE
SELECTION PROCESS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN.
YOU KNOW, WHAT PEOPLE THINK
MAKES -- WHAT A LOT OF KIND OF
POLITICAL PEOPLE THINK MAKE AS
GOOD CANDIDATE, A LOT OF
AMERICANS DON'T AGREE WITH
ANYMORE.
WE DON'T JUST WANT, LIKE, SINGLE
MEN WITH A LAW DEGREE.
WE WANT PEOPLE WHO FIX THINGS
FOR A LIVING, YOUNG MOMS.
PEOPLE THAT STRUGGLE TO GET A
MORTGAGE.
>> YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE MOMS.
YOU HAVE A 16-YEAR-OLD I KNOW.
A LOT OF FAMILY MEMBERS HERE.
CONGRESSWOMAN-ELECT SOON TO BE
CONGRESSWOMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FO